most people can't teach them like learn
on their own I agree um one thing that I
did when I lived in Milwaukee was I I
actually called c-level Executives and
asked them to like meet with me to get
like career advice a lot of people in
positions that you want
um to be in are willing to meet with you
and like Mentor like if someone called
you and said will you Mentor me if they
chased you down enough a lot of times
like these people will say yes yeah I
got the CIO of Harley-Davidson to meet
with me and that's a billion dollars
most people when they make money uh I
ask people this all the time I said all
right if you had five million dollars 10
million dollars 100 million dollars what
would you do with your free time all
right what would you do and everyone
says firsthand I travel I travel I want
to see the world I travel obviously okay
cool when you're done traveling you're
sick and tired what do you do you want
to pursue a passion because you've
already made your money you would do it
for free the third thing is they want to
give back and they want to donate when
you've made money and you've done stuff
in your life all you want to do is give
back to society that's why you're how
you're able to meet with these people
because they're like oh here's this
young girl that wants to learn hey come
right here bro yeah and I did that with
my manager too he was the manager
um at the daily wire and like Shapiro's
platform he ended up like quitting his
job to manage me but it all started with
me it all started with me saying hey
could I have some help with YouTube and
I was just dming like big media
companies and just asking like some of
their managers and some say no but
there's ways around it if you don't want
to spend I love this topic I love this
talk who are some of your mentors like
who are people you were like because
Destiny wasn't always the smartest guy
in the room you must have had to gone to
somebody to stop made I'm an island no
man is an island who said that streaming
didn't exist when I started as a
business you must have had some
inspiration are you really going to be
that guy that's saying that there's
nobody yeah nobody there's nobody who
looked up the [ __ ] would I look up to
there were no other streamers at the
time I'm in life you have nobody to look
up to no this is really bad advice this
is like horrible advice worst advice
ever I thought you looked up to me
good one maybe remember about standing
side by side but no
so there's nobody you're like all right
that guy's no but I'm an exception like
obviously because my my industry was
brand new I was like I grew up I'm not
talking about work I'm just talking
about in life there's nobody yeah no you
had no posters on your wall as a kid I
like video game characters okay okay
yeah who's poster was on your wall I
liked snake from Metal Gear Solid that
was like snake from Meadows I wish I
would have been cool enough to smoke
cigarettes like those guys but I never
I've actually never heard of that but
listen bro different show for who are
some of your mentors or Idols when you
were growing up that you were like all
right cool I want to kind of do what
they're doing uh I mean my dad obviously
um and then what about women
were there any female role models
because the knock on you is like you
hate women right but you are a woman so
do you hate yourself right which I don't
think you hate yourself I think you love
yourself but did you have female role
models or female that you looked up to
your mom of course okay other than
people that lived in your house
who did you look up to oh it was
probably more like volleyball players
like at the clubs that I was at so
um there's a girl named Abby gilland I
mean no no one would know who she is she
was a really good volleyball player at
my high school okay what about known
people that people would know like
what's your friend's name that you said
smoke cigarettes is cool it was a video
game yeah what is it snake from yeah
like nobody knows that person or at
least okay because you weren't a cool
kid exactly I wasn't a cool video game
nerd who did you look up to like so for
instance my favorite basketball player
nobody says this name everyone says
Michael Jordan or Magic Johnson LeBron I
loved Isaiah Thomas because he was six
foot and [ __ ] badass it was amazing
it was a point guard and I loved him and
he came from he went to Indiana he was
Detroit Pistons like I loved Isaiah
Thomas Isaiah if you see this love you
brother but like that was my guy because
I was a point guard I was a little bit
shorter I was like a quicker guy right
I'm six foot for the record
um so who famous did you look up to I
like that
don't think I'm like 5 10 or something
guys okay under six foot all right six
six figures six inches six foot now you
know thank you we got that shout out to
the red
um I don't really think I wasn't I
didn't watch sports I didn't really
watch we didn't nobody we didn't know we
didn't have TV house Jesus Christ what
kind of household did you live in I
thought your family made money yeah but
my my dad all right I'm moving on that's
it Alex give me something good Arnold
Schwarzenegger okay I wrote his book
like 20 times really yeah tell me what
that guy did for you he literally was
the go to three four different careers
he became the best bodybuilder he became
the top earning movie star he became the
governor uh that guy did so much the
fact that he was able to be successful
in so many different fields uh says a
lot about his mindset and he has at the
End of This Book he has like things that
made him successful his ten mindsets I
think that's such a great answer no
offense I know you had snake and Abby
the volleyball player that's great but
you you won the eyes on this one what
did you learn from Arnold Schwarzenegger
that you applied to your life I think a
big one was visualization so he talks
about how before you before you achieve
something you need to visualize it and
I've noticed all the autobiographies
I've read of successful people they all
have one thing in common is they
practice visualization so that was a big
one for me the second one was never
giving up but you got to have setbacks
that you're going to have times where
you think you're failing but if you
could just push through that then you
can come on the side I've personally
experienced that so yeah stuff like that
imagine where you would be right now if
you just had one Mentor in your life
just one well I visualize all the time
yeah what are you envisioning porn
what kind of porn do you watch by the
way don't worry about it well I'm very
worried right now you brought it up if I
bring it up you'll get banned on YouTube
all right let's switch gears right now
Nat how you doing over there who was
your hero growing up other than your mom
and dad and Adam you took him away yeah
I know I already beat you to the punch
yeah Mom and Dad not an acceptable
answer mom if you're watching this I
love you but you weren't my hero go
ahead I didn't really have like a
celebrity people I looked up to
um
I would say
um I I don't have an answer for you sick
answer or not you're killing the game
Kim Kardashian Kardashian is your hero
no I said what if I said Kim Kardashian
okay and you bring that up do you think
Kim Kardashian is a good role model for
most women today
no I mean no no why do you bring why did
you bring that up I'm a business
perspective and like marketing sure but
I I don't really agree with the way that
she got there but if you want to look at
outcomes sure
because why because she's a billionaire
now no she started with a sex tape oh I
know very funny it's hard for me to say
like if I look at the outcome of
billionaire that you can't learn
anything from Kim Kardashian wait [ __ ] I
wish I would have read this because I've
heard this talking about so many times
and I refuse to believe it's true she is
not a billionaire just because she had a
sex tape
sure I mean like that man have kicked
some things off but like there's a lot
of [ __ ] with sex tapes it was a
TV shows yeah it's just what made people
interested in her yeah okay because
there's a lot of uh there's a lot of
opportunities that you'll be presented
with in life that could be launching
pads to massive amounts of success yeah
yeah sure but like not everybody is in a
position like success is opportunity
meets preparation not everybody is in a
position to take advantage of the
opportunity if I make a sex tape No
One's Gonna exist yeah well I don't know
don't sell yourself sure don't say I've
heard good things about you what you got
going on there your girl's over there by
the way
um
real quick not let us know when we're
gonna get us some super chats what I
want to address them right now thank you
guys for being a very full disclosure
right that look forward to the sex tape
I look forward to hearing what kind of
porn you're watching these days what I
want to understand is that you were
recently on
a episode of Vice on a panel uh what you
were discussing feminism and modern
women what was the biggest takeaway from
that episode that you learned oh my gosh
that was the most crazy people I've ever
met in my life
um we were there for like six hours and
they edited it down to like 45 minutes
that's how editing works yeah where were
you in London um no I was in New York
okay New York gotcha um what was my
biggest takeaway
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible